thank you
[Music]
so the world's first empty autonomous
car has gotten into a police chase what
yes holy [ __ ] so empty police noticed
there was a car driving without its
headlights on is it one of those [ __ ]
rivian things what which car can drive
Chevy bolt Chevy ball Chevy Vulcan drive
Chevy bolt bolts bolt it sure wasn't a
PT Cruiser I saw the same thing with the
PT Cruiser this was a Chevy bolt PT
Cruisers are all electric now
[Music]
I haven't seen one in like 20 years dude
I see him all the time it's like the
[ __ ] dentist midlife crisis it's
pretty ugly man it's literally not with
the wood panels it's not it's the
ugliest car and these guys they think
they're gonna have some sort of diamond
that they keep in the garage when they
hit the front garage button and you see
it like oh my God it's a classic Hot Rod
style car I just want a kid hot rods
it's a modern hot rod I want to go there
and just [ __ ] take all the plastic I
could find and just melt it on the car
so it just sticks to the paint so cops
noticed that the headlights were not
turned on they and it was nighttime so
they're like okay well let's pull it
over so they pull it over
and I don't know how the [ __ ] they
pulled it over I just know that somebody
was in a bystander took video of this
empty vehicle that was pulled over
and then yeah the vehicle the cops were
walking up to it and the vehicle takes
off
and it's completely empty there's not
they the cops expect to see a person in
it there's no person in it and that's
all you can it wasn't a guy driving like
this with a gangster lean
a guy dressed like a car seat oh yeah
yeah that's what it is he's just hiding
in plain sight damn uh no so so the the
police chase started
and it ran it started to run from the
police but only for a short distance and
it was probably going the speed limit
right yeah and the and some people who
watch the video believe that the um
computer was moving to a safer place
oh because it was being pulled over in a
highway so it wasn't like christineing
itself
okay the AI and the car could tell when
it's being pulled over I don't know yeah
it's intelligent yeah
artificial intelligence can
I know the AI isn't like a move okay
is it like a move I'm sorry I just
missed Anthony I wish he was here
the rose will come here I'm sorry we got
us about you yeah we don't get the for
three days we gotta release it because
we gotta find the closest dancer we did
it via text but it wasn't the same yeah
we'll get the slams it's not the same
okay on the flip side at least Nina gets
to go in on him at home so do you think
Nina picks on him we should I really
want to know do you think Nina like
shits on him you know what's fine like
literally no whoa hey dude that's
inappropriate what's fun though is that
I think he gets it in all hours of the
day because we all know like like
sometimes I'll check my phone and I'm
like oh Bart texted us and I'm like oh
bars is roasting Anthony at 5 30 in the
morning
freaking Anthony piece of [ __ ] you know
what's funny though prior to JK I had
never seen anyone roast them really I
never I didn't even know that that's why
I love that's why I loved it here
one time I went to a McDonald's and we
went through the drive-through somebody
just threw a cheeseburgers yeah
I wish I could go back through and give
that guy a hundred dollar bill yeah no
it's like that's why I thought it was
cool because like it like I always said
like outside of here Anthony's just like
the he's the cool he's the cool guy
[ __ ] sex hat people just [ __ ]
celebrate his presence and then when
he's in here I think he kind of likes it
a little he's like getting a whip he's a
masochist yeah you think he's a pain
[ __ ] yeah
dude underneath all that [ __ ] pain
[ __ ] yeah yes don't give it away because
I've never seen that and I've known him
for years and I've never even like
socially been around with someone was
like ribbing him do you think it's
because no one has a sense of humor
around him
it could be it might be or maybe he's
just maybe he's just always in such a
high position that people like they're
afraid they just automatically it's
because he respects all and so they
respect him back yeah but so if he's
high status in the dance industry and
he's low status here does that make us
higher status than the dance industry in
general by default yeah right because if
he is our [ __ ] then in what the
hierarchy of they look up to him he
looks up to us so it's like that he
looks like this I think he goes JK okay
and then jabberwock is right under okay
okay and then Ken just like that oh no
no no
[Laughter]
Milwaukee's Quest periodics all the
winners of ABDC the winners and then you
have Tick Tock dancers and then you have
kinjaz and you have Anthony Lee top
dancers are both kids
hey man they're making millions dude
they're [ __ ] successful
has more members than Tick-Tock dancers
that's true that's true if they all just
started their own Tick Tock they'd be a
tick tock Empire but instead they want
to put all their efforts into one thing
that doesn't yeah
why don't they split they should and
individually make Tick Tock accounts I
think they already did split is the
problem is that nobody even knows
because there's so many [ __ ] kitchen
members oh and I've seen them dance
individually and they're all really good
they are they come together and they're
not good anymore oh they come together
they're not good
it's the only time where like the Power
Rangers get together and everyone's like
oh no
they don't fight enough don't make them
no more fun time
yeah no more fish it's like they're
beating up the bad guys as individual
Heroes and when they assemble they start
to lose and all the kids are like oh no
what is it aesthetically that that is
displeasing when watching hinges to you
like what do you feel you just it's like
this thing that makes you like taste
your bile oh yeah you're like what what
is that it is get this heartburn get
acid reflux
it just gives you I never had it before
and you gotta go get Tums or something
yeah yeah you gotta lay on your stomach
because you got tummy ache and [ __ ] yeah
the funny thing is I I didn't know how
long you guys were roasting them I
thought it was like a recent thing like
I thought for some reason I thought when
I came in like that's when you started
doing it and then I was looking for old
videos of Anthony on his birthday or
some [ __ ] and I found like the first
like times he was here and you guys were
already doing it
yeah it started from [ __ ] Bart and
and then I and then I went on and I saw
even the times before I was here and
like right when we beat him on ABDC and
you were making fun of him like that day
oh my God
on the the season eight let me show you
guys how I usually this is how I watch a
little and I can't just video when I'm
at home you know I like the Kinders dude
I like to do this and then I like to
like to click these three little dots
and then I click
of course
no no then I think promotes terrorism
oh
yeah he reported it to report the
terrorist
s reported it on the JK account oh no oh
no no don't do that our cow can't get
no this is in The Jig here okay don't do
that it's even better oh my god oh
Anthony that's what happens when you
catch Colvin man you just just get
[ __ ] up
foreign
[Laughter]
so it's not really a Chase then not
really a chase you think somebody was
like kind of remote controlling it it's
like that'd be a nice reveal if they
have a car parking function yeah so
maybe that's oh yeah Tesla's had that
you could like yeah it was Anthony Lee
be out of your car but in in California
they they're not allowed to have
self-driving yet right like full
autonomous I don't know I'm not sure
where was this this was uh this was in
California it was in San Francisco San
Francisco is a different state though
that's true practically yeah I don't
know
damn dude that's crazy right
I kind of want to talk more about Auntie
Lee now I think I think we should go
back to Anthony what else you got about
Anthony you know I personally I I really
like Anthony Lee I like the kinjas he
actually just texted us what'd he says
oh he texted me what do you say stop
talking about uh me stop talking [ __ ] no
he says what's the best way you're
getting money off the blockchain yeah
dude hey what I do is you leave leave
your money on the blockchain while I
make money you leave your money on the
blockchain I'll make money no the
two-man
you just end up scamming you just tell
them to [ __ ] pump this coin for you
oh my God you take his money it's like a
pillar scheme it's not even a pyramid
it's just you and him
foreign